okay good afternoon everybody welcome
back
lovely full room is so nice to see
everybody empty front row as ever
anyway welcome to this session on the
future of artificial perception
subtitled what can computers learn from
humans and I just liked very briefly
introducing our panelists we have Danica
Craddock from KT ha in Stockholm we have
a very rare phenomenon of a husband and
wife Nobel laureate team Edouard and my
Brit Moser 2014 Nobel laureates in
medicine and we have Maggie Bowden from
the University of Sussex who you met
this morning as well so this morning the
question one question came up in one
panel which was will AI be an evolution
of human intelligence and I guess that
sort of also would be a subtitle for our
panel because what we're going to ask is
how much our knowledge of human
perception and by extension human
intelligence will extend to the way we
develop intelligent computers and I
think we ought to begin by thinking
about how much we know about human
intelligence human perception so who
would like to describe our current state
of understanding of the biology of human
perception Maggie but first thing is
that as we discussed this morning
intelligence it's a very very broad
concept but each of the sub functions of
intelligence which we often call
cognition
I mean planning or thinking or memory or
learning or imagination I mean we are
beginning to understand how these things
work in the brain and so it's very
different from when we started in in
field of neuroscience um more twenty
almost thirty years ago and it's just a
black box now it's not a black box
anymore and I think we are starting to
see how neurons
groups on you and thousands of neurons
can actually collaborate to generate
these phenomena but at the same time I
think it's important to say that we are
just at the beginning and it's very very
complicated but you want to hear about
perception well since we've started with
intelligence we can come back to
perception but greatcoats file this
morning presented an idea of how one
model of how the brain might work can I
get your quick reaction to that ok never
mind a missed opportunity it's important
to define abilities because what what is
it and IQ tests for everything me being
psychologist that was almost a bad word
because it's so cultural independent the
way we were taught to think about
intelligence because it was measured by
tests that we're not they're really
biased but of course intelligence is
about survival and it's also about
emotional intelligence and I think
emotional intelligence is what makes us
human and and I'm not on the on the
question of understanding what that is
we're really nowhere I assume I mean we
understand sir from your from work from
you and from others we understand
something about how we perceive space
I mean space is just an example of the
fact if they're beginning to understand
some of the what we believe are the
basic algorithms of the brain or of the
cortex and I think one of the reasons
why we are studying space is that you're
not only interested in space as such but
because it's a window into areas of the
cortex that we know much much less but
it still tells us something about this
algorithm
and those are the algorithms that
probably are or interest artificial
intelligence not exactly how neurons do
what what are the rules that the brain
uses but when you hear that people are
trying to develop artificially
intelligent systems based on our
knowledge of how the brain works do you
think our knowledge of how the brain
works is sufficient for them to be
working on that already how do you think
that the connection is there yet
I noticed this morning when the cookies
questions came up there was a sort of
silence about the connection between
biology and how did our brain develop it
was not only to reduce intelligence but
the computer if you develop a computer
you want to have an intelligent robot or
whatever you want intelligent machine so
our brain contains so much more than
intelligence so to learn from the brain
and just cope it maybe it's not useful
artificial intelligence can machines can
be so intelligent without using what we
know from the brain it's probably very
useful you have to confirm that but it's
very useful to know about algorithms or
the ways that the brain does it and may
serve as a really useful guideline and I
guess that's what's happening partly now
in AI that actually the mechanism that
the brain uses or is believed to use is
actually used by computers but of course
computers are very different so I mean
it has to be done but the principle
still can be transferred country there
are very many different different
reasons why and why studies in humans or
in general in biological systems are
relevant for artificial systems the
first one is to of course understand the
principles or the processes of how
things were information is processed in
the brain right and we can draw a
parallel with birds and airplanes
airplanes do not fly as birds but are
basically
build on the technology of understanding
how birds fly okay but it's not as
effective or not as optimal to build
artificial systems that fly as birds so
if you draw that perilous understanding
the brain and the processes in brain can
tell us something about how information
is processed in order to build or be
inspired for for building artificial
systems but not copy it necessarily okay
so that's one thing the other aspect is
the structure the structural aspect
right so what is the hardware and how
does the hardware work and that can also
serve as inspiration for building
sensory systems today we do have
examples of like visual systems or
cameras that work for example with the
visual system in the fly or works and so
on and it gives the possibility to
systems to be devoted to specific
applications so understanding why fly or
other biological system has developed
the sensing or perceptual system can
make similar and we can draw parallels
to that but also the artificial systems
for the future are there to help human
in some way to interact with humans and
so on and in order to be able to do that
the machines also need to understand the
human way of interaction with the
environment okay so this is really
really important because if you want to
have a robot that is a little bit more
than a vacuum cleaner robot you talk to
a robot you can send to places a robot
that does not use only metric
information because humans do not really
use what's of metric information right
we have different types of topological
maps and so on we talk about relations
well you will find the PR room in the
hallway to the right I mean we use went
Mart's and so on an understanding of
those processes and how we use natural
language to actually convey that the
wave is stored information and so it's
also an inspiration of making machines
that can be more human-friendly
in terms of interaction that can make
themselves understood by humans but
taking the analogy of birds and planes
sure when when humans learnt to fly they
copied some aspects of birds that
weren't actually right to copy and then
they kind of gradually got closer to
work working out how birds actually flew
but when we look at brains and
intelligent computers how back to this
first question of how much do you think
we understand about the way that the
brain processes space and so how far
along the road to understanding are we
and how much and therefore how valuable
it is is it for people developing
artificial systems to try and copy that
or should they be waiting until we
understand more I think one should try
to copy it when one thinks one
understand I mean it's a mutual dialogue
but I will also emphasize that the
process of understanding the brain is
much much slower than the development of
computer technology so I think that is a
challenge for AI that is not all that
fast I mean little thing I mean in terms
of understanding principles that's
actually many of the principles that
guide out here is today or developed so
we can talk about some of the ongoing
projects also in Europe where the the
idea is if we can build artificial
systems that perform at a human level on
the data that humans use in their
everyday life and that to some extent
also have the structure capabilities
that that or the structure that may be
human brain has that we can also do in a
way reverse engineering so understand
human way of acting up I'm just saying
there are most of people that believe in
that that's possible of doing so
building artificial systems that would
give them better understanding of how
human brain breaks thank you which is
hugely important and interesting in
itself and may well turn out to be and
was already to some extent being helpful
that's not just the only question the
question is not just how is the
information handled by the brain but
what information is it in other words
psychological questions which have to be
answered in computational terms and what
sorts of computation what sorts of
information does our do our
psychological studies tell us that
whether the brain is actually handling
and until you've got clear about those
questions you have got a chance of being
clear about how even knowing how to ask
you know where to look how the brain
does it and I think that's very often
forgotten and I mean in this case for
example I mean when people talk about
you know huge advances that they've been
in machine perception was vision for
example and they give examples like you
know now recognizing a cat's face from a
dog's a discriminating captain a dog and
using big data and machine learning all
that yes yes yes but of course this is
something that we can do and which
previously Isis was couldn't do so
that's all fine but human vision isn't
just for recognizing things it's also
for you know giving what psychologists
Gibson called affordances no recognizing
what possibilities for action what
opportunities to this particular
spatially you know spatial phenomenon
offer and that's hugely important and
there's none of that in all this you
know cat's face recognizes stuff at all
so that's really important and also I
mean when we look at something um very
often always certainly very very often
we have all sorts of other things going
on not just in our heads but I would say
you know in our vision then just
recognizing something we see an analogy
it may be a you know a spatial analogy
to something else or perhaps to a
painting that we saw once and or perhaps
to a mythical figure a painting that's
important because of the mythological
story that
telling now all of this it seems to me
it is part of vision you could say well
it's not vision it's thinking which is
triggered by vision you could put it
that way but anyway it seems to me it's
very very closely linked and until we
get machines the visual machines you
know that can do that we can't claim
that they've approached human vision and
again as well as I know there's no work
on that I can I can out the affordances
you're talking about or as people have
called it and tried it's functional
categories it's actually a very very
difficult task and very often I ask
people ok and our job is about writing
computer programs that take video
sequences and try to understand them so
building really complicated models based
on many examples but a very simple
question what is a chair ok yeah and
then you know people look at me ok it's
not a tricky question ok what's a chair
and then 99 percent of people will
answer something I can sit on and then I
say ok I can sit on the floor I can sit
on the table what's not a chair so for
the computer program they are not so
very good in understanding what's not a
specific category right and how to find
the differences between something that
has a function and the does not have a
function I have a one and a half year
old at home that and her brain obviously
understood the shape but not the
function yet and it's really interesting
to see because I would have never never
I think noticed that so so she has a
chair for her doll ok that she's trying
to sit on and the chair is approximately
this side fantastic video that I use in
my lectures now because she has the
shape information in her brain but not
yet the function so I asked Elizabeth
what are you trying to do sit sit sit
and you know she's just throwing and
falling down all the time and it's
really interesting this is exactly how
for the future that's going to be a
problem for for computer systems in
general to understand what's not a good
example
but yeah I think what you are talking
about is often what we in your science
call
top-down processes because even the
simplest thing like just seeing or
recognizing visual image is actually
influenced by everything else that the
brain knows and everything else that
happens simultaneously in the brain has
to go back and that's why we humans or
other animals are so good at
distinguishing a chair from a non chair
which is so difficult for a computer and
then I think that's one thing more we
can do which animals and humans do is
that not only can you distinguish but
you actually know you know a lot about
probabilities which you can then use to
guide behavior so for example when you
run through a big lots of people on the
street you manage to navigate your way
because you know how likely it is that
he or she walks left or right and bumps
into you so you can use all of this
information together with all the input
that comes in at the same time just to
interpret this little image that's you
can do that know that that's exactly
said I think that very many times I we
forget that our visual perception
systems in general are not you know
hundred percent so to speak because we
do fail a lot but the thing is that they
had developed so that we can actually
manage in the world around us but lots
of intelligence is also in the body so
it's not about only how we see and
perceive images is also what and how the
the things and the objects in the
environment can be used by our bodies
and what I usually say when you talk
about the analogy is trying to flip the
pancake it's more likely to use a knife
right if I don't have a spatula than a
spoon but if I mix a soup and I don't
have something to steer with I will more
likely use a spoon than a knife and
that's basically you know the the the
the heart of the functional categories
we are able to generalize we use lots of
experiences that you know we have used
those things we know what those
functions are and that's what machines
are still good from where I'm
sitting it sounds like a fairy
insurmountable task to bring all that to
bear on a machine but we'll come back to
that I really want to involve the
audience in this discussion as well so
we have some circulating microphones I
believe yes they're all back at the
moment but they'll come forward would
anybody like to make a comment or
question about what we're talking about
at the moment feel free if you do
waiting for the audience no because that
was when when our children were young
they had to read these novels and one
was so fascinating it was about this
robot that should help a person to get
up from the bed go to the bathroom eat
and all the time and and one morning he
took this person in the chair was wrong
because he was wrong but as you say what
is the difference between a human being
and I compute that computer hasn't
experienced to give food to a dead
person before and didn't have that in
the program there is also another
important point I think and that that is
it humans learn and then we forget
certain things okay like mathematics
maybe that we have learned like 20-30
years ago we don't necessarily know it
as as we knew it at some point but from
machines we expect that they learn and
remember everything okay and that's also
going to be one of the problems because
the model said we need to use you know
become much more complex and at some
point not necessarily we can even if you
would know how human brain works given
that we don't have this forgetting
factor in the machines that's the way I
think after all these people who can't
forget they have disappeared
autobiographical memory but it affects
other it affects other parts therapy
they can't even forgive ya and that's
and that's a big problem that's exactly
the neuro scientists on the panel about
the brain we know that robots have
algorithmic brains what about human
brains do they work on algorithms or
something else we found a grid cell and
it looks like a mathematical function
it's equilateral triangles like in my
bag that I got from the designer made
like my dress so there's of course
mathematics in the brain but it's not so
simple because there are all kinds of
functions human brain is not very
different at the algorithmic level from
a rat brain or a mouse brain or even an
insect brain I mean the basic roots are
the same all the way it's just like DNA
DNA works the same way in a human being
as in a yeast cell so it's I think the
basic rules are the same and since we
know it's so so similar in that Mouse in
a rat or in a bat or in a monkey then
although we know much less about human
brains extremely unlikely that humans
would have developed on a different path
but can I just add sir I just wanted to
say that the matrix example of the story
about the dead person and the robot
reminds me of a very very interesting
case I'm trying to remember the name of
the book or the author in which I read
it years ago and I can't but I remember
the example very very well well this
person was a psychologist he was
teaching a course in psychology to
medical students who were already in
their clinical training so they were
working in the hospital and various
parts of the hospital already and she
showed them a photograph
of a baby I know just a few months old
sitting up against a brick wall with a
white sort of dress thing on and she
said you know what's wrong with this
baby oh yeah how would you diagnose this
baby and it went on and on and on and on
and they discussed and they discussed
and discussed and while they were
discussing one person said was very
well-cared-for baby because look at that
spotless white nitrus that she's in and
another one said well yes but I mean
it's not very kind to put a baby up
against the brick wall so they they were
worrying about this anyway to cut a long
story short it turned out that the baby
was a dead baby who was in the hospital
morgue which the students being already
clinical students had visited had seen
and they had picked up the fact of that
brick ball they'd picked up the what
they called the night dress which of
course was the hospital shroud but
because they just expected to be looking
at living children in order to try and
help them in some way by diagnosing what
was wrong with them in the first place
it just never occurred to them that it
could be a dead baby she had to point it
out yes and they but they were giving
being given apparently you know a sort
of purely visual test you may look at
this baby and see no look for symptoms
of illness and which do you find they
didn't find any if you want to talk
mathematically about things then then we
talked about priors or prior information
that somehow it affected the model or
decision model or the expert system and
I think that having this prior
information so have I been in this
situation before or how other people
have done or performed in a situation
like this before effects lot of other
performance and our behavior and daily
basis
and today when we build computer systems
we put lots of prior information in it
so if you talk about so-called
supervised learning we put labels on
images and so on but the problem is that
lots of this prior information makes
sense because we have the body we have
we do the things we do and in the future
robots may have very different body than
the human has and the priors that make
sense to us may not have any effect or
or or let's say even good effect on
their robots learning capabilities and
that's an important issue also to
discuss we've set up this panel to
investigate what computers can learn
from humans and we've established very
much that there's all sorts of human
animal behaviors that will be extremely
difficult to replicate in computers
because there is so much association but
presumably and the pace of the pace of
discovery in biology is going to be too
slow to really inform this rapid
development of computers to a major
extent so maybe maybe computers are
going to in fact not learn all that much
except for this basic paradigm of
needing to be have have multiple inputs
to understand anything and then go their
own way absolutely learning certain
things takes a really long time so one
should not forget about that and even
things we learn we do sometimes change
the way we think about things or the way
we do things you know if we see it from
the beginning we learn to do something
and then we see somebody doing something
in a more effective or optimal way we
have a tendency of adopting that that
way of doing things and so on so I think
that that it is really really important
to understand biological systems and I
think in terms of perception we have a
good understanding for example of how
the AI work very precisely we do have an
understanding of where the information
is processed in the brain when it comes
to visual information when it comes to
motor information we also know a lot
about that there is lots of interaction
with this
two areas because we look and we do
things and so on so that that definitely
serves as a good inspiration for us
building I'd like to invite more
questions but what's your feeling about
the Blue Brain Project and these these
efforts to understand to map the entire
but there's something that is so
exciting because we know that the brain
is so important for perception like you
say and still I find it so surprising
when you see a rat
eating sugar or chocolate and if you
stimulate the sensor or bitterness in
the brain and the mouse order a system
and you know it's sugar but of course
you stimulated the site that is
recording bitterness so it again it's
the brain something about the Blue Brain
Project I think my personal view is that
it's far too early to simulate an entire
brain or even just a little part of the
brain but nonetheless simulation as such
I think is very important but the way I
think simulation or computational
neuroscience as we call it works best is
when you you have an idea and a model
hypothesis and then you try to figure
out how could this be sold by a certain
group of neurons my impression of much
of the work in the Blue Brain Project is
that is driven from a different way of
approaching science which may also be
valid but is more bottom-up while you
sort of collect data and see how they
fit together maybe something pops up so
there are different traditions I think
my starting point and my dreams of
course too is that I think still what
drive science is having hypotheses and
then test them out and also if you
understand how a computer works you
don't know what you get out if you
change the input and that's the same
went with the brain so it depends on how
the brain is wired what kind of
information you have it's like people
when they talk about cloning you cannot
clone a person whatsoever because a
person is not only genes a person is
also experienced so and the blue brain
yes they have this tiny part that they
can probably describe and that's
important to no small parts but to
explain the whole brain had a question
here she was first I'm sorry I didn't
see you I apologize okay I was wondering
how do we prevent like the self learning
machine from picking up the worst of our
habits or behaviors like what type of
implementation should we have to stop
them from learning the things we don't
want them to learn from humans there
have been discussions before lunch also
about the danger of self learning
machines and not knowing what what it is
and so on I'm a strong believer in that
when we develop machines that that are
able to think and so develop in some way
that they should also have teachers as
humans have okay and something that we
have is both understanding of ethics and
moral and that's something that we don't
discuss enough how do we make sure that
the rules that are used to guide the
learning process are also come you know
conveying or the ethics and moral and
also having some form of external
teacher that can say this is a good and
this is a bad outcome of a learning
session and I think that there is a lots
of
discussion about that in several
communities computer vision machine
learning and so on we talk about
supervised learning we talk about
semi-supervised learning but there is
also lots of discussion about completely
unsupervised learning so just having
lots of data and then learning something
and that's very difficult I think that
the machines that learn without the
teacher can are very limited I don't
think the day these machines can learn
anything on a pretty kind of like high
level making the generalizations and
understanding affordances I don't think
that that will come to the machines
especially not to machines that are not
embodied okay because I think that lots
of intelligence we have is in the way we
interact with environment that's
something that you said experiences that
together throughout the life is also
what we physically do with the body
so I think that that having
semi-supervised systems and using the
teacher in the loop can achieve that and
then of course having the rules that
they're based on that take some more
curiosity was mentioned earlier today as
being a key part of intelligence of
human intelligence and and many learning
systems learn what we ask them to learn
and this connects of course they would
to what done it suggests said that how
curiosity could be considered some kind
of meta urge to sort of learn things
that we don't know and you know to
conquer new esthetic domains or
understand something that we don't even
know what to do with how do we I would
like to hear your reflections on how how
do we actually implement this in
machines it's connects to creativity of
course it connects to aesthetic
experiences etc and those are key
elements of human intelligence how do we
deal with that I think curiosity as you
implied in your question comes out of a
knowledge that you don't know something
an understanding maybe you'd only to a
very very limited degree because you
find that you can't do something which
you wanted to do and so obviously you
don't know how to do it so you need to
find out sometimes you know much more
wide and interesting than that where
you're thinking about a some interesting
complex area of human knowledge for
example and for a an AI system to
realize if you like but it doesn't know
something when it isn't just a question
of you know there is a particular
measurement for example that it needs to
know if it wants to lift this cup you
know and it hasn't it looks for the
measurement it hasn't got it
so the program could say well you know
go and find it so yeah okay no problem
but if we're talking about the more
interesting sorts of case where we would
talk about curiosity where as I think
you you suggested you aren't even
necessarily looking to solve a
particular sort of problem you're just
interested you don't know and maybe you
think maybe nobody else knows either and
that's especially interesting so how can
you find out now the sort of meta
knowledge if you like the sort of self
knowledge that you need about your own
intellectual competence and your own
degree of learning is you know miles
away miles away from anything that
exists or even is being approached or
attempted in AI today I'm not saying
it's in principle impossible I don't
think the human brain works by magic and
I don't think therefore that the human
mind works by magic and so I don't think
it's in principle impossible that's not
what I'm saying but I'm saying it's a
hugely difficult in some ways that we
sort of begin to understand in some ways
that we don't many ways we don't yet
understand hugely difficult and would be
hugely expensive and who would want to
put the money in and as I think it was
Barbara said this morning there are very
other ways you know much cheaper
okay roses perhaps to make new human
intelligence why put a little money into
human level AI so very shortly Polly hi
and so in Robotics community people talk
about encoding drives for like you know
learning or driving they did the
curiosity but for me when it comes to
humans you always have the curiosity
driving either the the lack of knowledge
in something right or because you have
some artistic let's say you won't
explore something and see what the
result of that would be and in principle
that wouldn't be difficult to program in
machines those types of drives but what
would one do with that we see today
robots made making paintings right but
we also have experiments showing that if
a human perceiver knows that it's
painted by a robot it has less value
than if it's painted by a human okay so
what's the value for the main kind of a
curious robot that's an important thing
to think about but also it's in the
mathematics we use to drive the periodic
and that's that many of the mathematical
models are today based on looking into
correlations between data so trying to
find similarities right and there is
this very known book or experiment
showing that using just looking into
correlation curves or something like
that there are very many things in life
that correlate but the correlation
itself does not really make any sense so
we need to be really really careful in
what kind of mathematical models are
used to really drive the curiosity but
that also have a good values and think
of what's the curiosity for Christian of
the bad please yes I can't see but I'm
having it pointed is there somebody here
no okay yeah are talking about humans
perception we intrinsically has have
very high level of integration of
different channels of information vision
tactile information hearing
so what the state of art to implement
that on algorithmic way in machines and
also which ways we can see how we can
achieve the progress in this area in
machines thank you so lovely summary
question because we don't have very long
so let's make that our last question
this is my area of research we can talk
for 45 minutes after but the the the
research has come pretty far in terms of
addressing or integrating different
types of sensing modalities as I usually
say when working with robots and
artificial sensing we also have to work
with sensing that humans don't have such
as for example the ability to measure
distance humans cannot do that not in
metric coordinates right but we can put
a laser or sonar on a robot and get the
metric information out directly so no
it's not so much in terms of integrating
the sensory information is about
representing it so how do we use the
sensory knowledge and how do we make
sure how do we assess that the right
sensor or sensors are used for the right
task so for example lifting a cap from
the table it's not necessarily that I
need to visually guide my arm you know
in order to pick it up it's already in
my map you too can say more about that
but I basically can use or will rely
much more on my tactile sensing right if
I want to kind of be polite to look at
you while I'm doing that so I think that
the the modeling the way of integrating
sensing sensory information one
additional question probably related to
this which is that at least in in humans
we are bombarded by inputs all the time
and it could be the same in robot too
but then you have to select what is
relevant and what is not relevant and
that's I imagine that's a very
challenged by the right sensing for the
for the Tusken yeah any closing thoughts
about the hope of having artificial
systems that can perceive the world in a
useful in a useful way I mean for
instance if you want a an AI system that
will recognize a particular sort of
cancer cell just as reliably in fact in
some cases much more reliably than they
highly-paid human exist but extending
into the future well but maybe a little
bit on the side but I can imagine that
you can have interactions between AI and
biological systems such as artificial
vision and also cochlear implants where
I think the difference is that a nervous
system the brain has to learn how to
interpret the signals but that I can
imagine can happen and that's not so far
maybe into the future I think that just
a small example I say that there is
currently no robot in the world that can
do dishes ok very complex task or for
example being able to cut any loaf of
bread or any kind of like so there there
are challenges in terms of equipping
artificial systems with the capabilities
that humans do almost without any mental
difficulty and I think it's a it's
bright future in terms of understanding
how some of the perceptual systems in
human inhuman work in order to
understand what would be kind of like
the challenges for the technical systems
you know to go further and then do
dishes at some point and as the last
thought is the speed of progress is the
rate of progress in neuroscience going
to speed up yes neuroscience is going to
speed up
student we learnt about the brain as a
black box and now we know so much okay
nice hopeful messages thank you very
much indeed all panelists thank you